hey guys and welcome back to leia
inspired powered by icon plus it's so
great to have you all here so since this
is powered by icon plus i'm gonna start
with a really quick news um announcement
for you so quite interesting actually
korea's largest bank shinhan bank and
icon launch shinhan bank kyc
authentication on icons my id and with
shin hands affiliates also joining
customers can now remotely open accounts
across financial institutions with one
my id login so some very interesting
news coming out from the icon network
there
so today if you haven't guessed i have a
very interesting guest joining me um he
is sort of known as a twitter
philanthropist sending thousands of
dollars across the internet so of course
joining me today is bill plute bill
great good to be with you
thanks for having me
yeah it's great to have you so we've
sort of just connected through twitter
it's 2020 it's kind of just what
way the world happened now
literally and you have completely taken
charity to a whole new level um i see
constantly it's sort of like this tweet
i'm paying for somebody's dinner um
retweet this i'm sending a bunch of
money to a lot of veterans and i think
this is so interesting so i'm super
excited to understand your background
how you got here and everything that's
going on so sort of talk to me firstly
about the most that you've actually sent
through twitter i know that trump
retweeted you about a year ago
um so how much
well i've given away a bunch of
different amounts ten thousand i just
did i think what is probably my biggest
giveaway so far which is 50 000
and yes i actually did pay it you know a
lot of people say they don't say it
anymore but when i first started they
thought it was like a scam or that it
wasn't real um and now it turns out you
know i'm the real guy and everybody's
asking me you know are these other
people paying but i paid fifty thousand
dollars and then you may have seen that
uh with the famous youtuber mr beast who
i'm sure you've heard of him and i gave
away a hundred thousand dollars together
so those would probably be the two
biggest ones we've done
yeah and it's interesting because before
i had you one i was obviously doing my
research finding out a little bit more
about you so you have chatted a bit it's
good just to find out a bit more and
like you said people were calling it a
scam
because it's crazy how much money you're
sending over the internet so you kind of
popped out of nowhere you've already got
i think it's just over three million
followers um on twitter alone so where
did this come from i know there's polte
group so where did this philanthropist
in you come from and when did you get
the idea to do twitter well my
grandfather's name was bill pulte and he
was a very wealthy guy very good guy uh
born in 1932 so
depression-era guy
and him and i got along very well and
and i learned a lot from him in terms of
business and then at age 23 i started my
own business which was to acquire other
companies and frankly leia over the last
10 years i've just done extremely well
financially i didn't ever think that i
would be
as successful financially as i had
become
obviously i learned a lot from my
grandfather so that was very helpful
people sometimes think i inherited money
uh i hope i didn't inherit money and i
haven't uh because my dad hasn't died
yet and my dad's obviously my
grandfather's kid so
uh in any event um i've made a lot of
money i'm 32 years old and i say to
myself you know why the hell are we not
giving money away on the internet and so
i had this idea to give away 10 000 and
the next thing you know the whole thing
went viral i mean it went everywhere and
i had enough credibility on twitter that
people knew it was probably real and and
and whatnot and so went viral and then
twitter philanthropy was born and it's
just been it's just been a viral deal
ever since then
i have a really
niggling question right so you know you
send bitcoin sometimes and i'm in crypto
um as a lot of people know and often
people will say to you anyway everybody
who's watching this we got about 1 500
live viewers which is good
when you're doing this so i have a lot
of my teammates around so they'll
probably i'll go follow you when we're
done
that's kind thank you so much just so
much so much charity i'm loving it too
kind
but you know people often a lot of the
time when somebody wins the lottery for
example they don't want people to know
how much money they have one of the main
things about crypto is you know people
like to say anonymous they don't want
people to know because often you get
fake people coming to you um not even
fake people just giving you a fake
scenario saying please like give me more
money like how do you navigate through
that because once you give
how do you sort of draw that line and
you know when someone dms you or
something and says um oh gosh you know i
helped pay my family's medical bills
what do you do how do you emotionally
detach yourself and draw that line
well it's very emotionally difficult and
you're astute for picking that up a lot
of people don't realize how hard it is
and again
people are going through a lot more
suffering than you and me or ever are
out there so i'm very sensitive to that
but i've had people say to me this is so
hard being able to figure out what's
going on i have total respect for what
you're doing you know once they try to
do it for a day or two um so i would
just say that you know over time you
develop an instinct and my thought is
that look
if 90 of the people that i help are good
people which i assume uh you know my my
world view is basically that ninety
percent of people are good people uh and
ten percent of people um you know either
misguided or what have so if ten percent
of them are scams i'm fine with those
odds because you know what for what
you're saying about the internet and
everything uh that happens in life i
mean people have been getting scammed
and uh stolen money from for for
centuries thousands of years actually
and the only difference which is why
it's more visible now is that the
information flow or the amount of people
that are potentially able to access it
in a quicker fashion right if you think
about it like let's say there's some
scammer in new york on the streets of
new york well if you're in los angeles
you're not going to necessarily see that
scammer
but if all of a sudden you
have an internet
then somebody in los angeles can see a
scammer in new york that's just the way
the world is going so
i view it as a uh
problem as old as
as the world uh it's nothing new it's
just technology gets us to think
differently about the problem and we're
trying to think differently about
philanthropy
so on a small small scale if i may i can
oh gosh the audio is is a bit rough i'm
not sure what's going on hopefully that
might pass
is it rough on your end the audio it is
when you talk but i don't know if it is
when i talk
okay i'm hoping we can sort of
sort this out um okay so on a small
scale i can sort of relate to you
because i often find that um a lot of
the time there are people potentially um
homeless on the streets and they often
come to you and they ask for money and
sometimes you don't know whether they're
scamming you in some respect you know or
whether you know their cause is actually
genuine um so i have a similar mentality
and i'm kind of just like okay if i give
a couple pounds a couple dollars um it
shouldn't be the end of the world just
to sort of see what i mean yes i do very
much so and i'm just checking here the
feed to see because it says we have zero
people in here which doesn't make any
sense no no it says we have a thousand
so i think we're good yeah we got a
thousand
i'm just not sure what's going on with
the audio i might take my airpods out
and uh see if it see if the audio fixes
if that works because i know that you
can
yeah are you there
i can't hear your audio but uh but then
but the crackling went away
but anyway while you figure that out
i'll go ahead and answer which is just
yeah it's the same situation that you
have when you give a homeless person
money or when you give anybody money for
that matter i mean you're always taking
that risk but what i try to do or how i
try to program my brain is basically to
tell myself okay bill like i'll give you
an example yesterday or not yesterday
two days ago
i was giving money to a guy who's on the
side of the road and you know my first
instinct is like hey you know what
probably everybody's instinct is but if
you start to look at that person as a
human being
and say you know what maybe that person
you know needs a little bit of a hand up
you know it kind of changes your world
view and so i'm just trying to change a
little bit of the world of view
as it's known
um
on the internet from all this hate and
vitriol everybody's hating on each other
these days and we are a um
we are a safe haven of people helping
people
yeah absolutely so hopefully my audience
it's still on the place with it
yeah it's doing it when you do it is it
doing it when i do it because i don't
hear it yours is a little bit rough is
mine entirely ruffle can you hear me is
it still okay
i can still hear you a little bit but
yeah it's it's a little rough yours is
but mine's fine i don't know if that's
me or what
but okay all right i don't know so i'm
going to ask you a question another
question and what do you want to figure
out what you answered so i want to keep
this going um
i wonder whether you had an opinion on
how to practice your money because
you're essentially going directly to the
people cutting out that middle man so i
wonder if you've had anything um issues
with that middle man whether you think
there's something better about going
directly to the person whether it be
charities take the amount of money so
i'm going to talk about my audio
yeah well basically you know there's no
middleman in the sense that when i go to
give somebody money on cash app i don't
have to pay for the fancy charity
executives to go and uh you know have
the ball or you know a
fancy catering and alcohol and all this
other kind of stuff you know i don't
need to pay for all that overhead i can
just go ahead boom and send money to
somebody so so yes i think that that has
been very attractive and i think what's
also attractive is that so many of the
people who are on twitter who see me
helping people what
they're doing is
they're helping out other people and
they're able to see people on my feet
and they're able to send money to people
and that's what i'm really interested in
is having a viral community of givers
because if i'm just bill pulte giving
away money you know i can only give out
so much money right just math and so um
you know what happens when i run out of
money right so we need to create a
community of givers who have the same
passion of helping people and you know
we posted yesterday for example a
gentleman he has a
hospital bill i think for something like
50 600 or something and he's dying of
cancer i think he's dying of cancer and
it's terrible you know he's trying to
fight it and god willing he fights it
but
we're going to be able to get him 5600
now imagine if he had to go through a
bunch of charity and a bunch of red tape
and all this crap and no boom i can just
pop it right up on twitter and by the
way if anybody's watching hasn't donated
please go on my page and do that but
um you know that's what i think is so
exciting about what we're doing
so why do you think
people aren't necessarily doing it so
much so what's in here um a lot of
different um celebrities will sort of
say
you know whether it comes to like
another culture or whatever it is
they'll often say um you know you normal
people should take
mad
you know we can't do as much as you guys
can do
so
why aren't they doing it and how can we
get more people to do it
well it's a great question i don't
totally know the answer but what i
believe is that small changes made over
a long period of time on a persistent
basis will yield change
and so we've only been doing this for a
year and if you think about it we've
made basically celebrities giving away
money on twitter like a hot thing i mean
it's like i mean cardi b is giving away
money jeffree star mr beast i've seen
ninja help out people on there so um so
i do think people are catching the bug
it's just i don't know any other way
than to lead by example
and to try to get as many of those
people involved which i've which i've
worked very hard to get them involved
okay so you're working hard to get these
big names involved you mentioned cardi b
um you know that's she's doing it um
what about um new upcoming sort of
people that we can expect to start
getting involved do you have interesting
partnerships and more people joining
that we can expect to see some
incredible twitter
well the thing that i think is probably
the biggest thing is that
in my opinion the pandemic moved forward
the digitization of the economy yeah i
think 10 or 20 years and so when you
have that kind of pull forward inertia
some things get a lot more attention
i'll give you an example
cache app by square for example now
before you had venmo and you had these
other things but if you look at the
functionality of cache app for example
what they've been able to do is really
create a viral thing i mean whether it's
cardi b giving away money etcetera and
people have the cash app so i think over
time you know it's just my opinion
nobody listens to my advice but
uh that these that these cash apps and
you know things like cash app are
probably going to eat away at the banks
and eat away the whole banking system
you know they sell bitcoin on there
which i know you're a big fan of
and so i just think that you know we
just have to be patient and i actually
think that you'll be surprised
technology and this this crisis this
crazy crisis this crazy pandemic
does have some silver linings in the
sense that uh some of the technological
changes that would have happened over
10-15 years are now happening in terms
of philanthropy that's actually i mean
you're going to see some things that
aren't so good on a short term basis but
over time if we can lower cost of goods
and if we can help people
um and help more people uh through the
the greater technology being implemented
to me i think that we're that much
closer to getting widespread
philanthropy
and i think you make a really
interesting point about this pandemic
and how it's sort of been a catalyst
everything forward essentially um from a
technological perspective so you
you um to send money across people this
is cool this is a fantastic youth case
this is that's an incredible marketing
plan
so talking about
why bitcoin how did you get into this
well
bitcoin you know
so first of all i subscribed to the idea
that the government um you know has
certain bounds as to what it can do in
terms of printing money and and all that
you could look at bitcoin you know i
happen to believe that the bitcoin paper
uh by satoshi was probably the greatest
computer science deal that's happened in
a long time at least since the the
internet
and how he designed it on a
decentralized basis on a trustless basis
absolutely brilliant so
so first of all government printing
second of all you know mathematically
it's as far as i'm concerned it's
brilliant um and number three and i
would say probably most importantly
because a lot of the people who say oh
bitcoins you know not gonna make it or
whatever i would just look at adoption
and um if you look at some of these
countries like africa you look at some
of these countries that don't have
stable currencies and who knows the gov
united states government may eventually
be there i i
i don't actually think that the
government will be there that's my own
my own thought in terms of really being
trash currency i don't think that's
going to happen i mean
it's just i i don't see how
even if you have massive inflation yeah
you have the world's largest inventory
so i'm not one of these guys that says
oh this guy's falling you know you need
to go buy bitcoin because of that but
i do think that the adoption is going to
really pick up in the united states i
think it already is picking up in the
united states i think it's picking up in
these developed worlds and i think the
genie is out of the bottle but who knows
the us government could ban it i don't
know
so there's two points here but so the
first point um i just kind of want to
get into is how you put into bitcoin
though because a lot of the time it can
um
perceive just like a scam or whatever or
second point
um
about adoption like which i bought you
but specifically when did you first hear
about bitcoin
um
i think in like 2015 something like that
and you know
i just like how electronic it was how
you know again i've had success in
business so i've wired large amounts of
money and when you wire large amounts of
money um the the rigmarole that you have
to go through is crazy
and so
when i when i was sending bitcoin
to myself or different people i was like
holy hell you can give away all this
money that quickly that doesn't make any
sense this is this is a disruptive
technology and i think anybody who
underestimates bitcoin in my opinion
uh does so at their own risk i think
it's very foolish um it's my opinion
i'm totally with you so you are sending
money with bitcoins people across the
other side of the world
what really interesting is that people
um in likes of south america or africa
and so on they may not have let's talk
about africa actually they may not have
um the kind of financial infrastructure
that you see to the extent that we have
in the west um but they have internet
connection and they have smartphones um
and that for me is the coolest part of
blockchain technology
even if you wanted to send the money
with fear with dollars you literally
because you didn't have a way to access
it
correct correct and i think it can i
think you can do more for world poverty
than almost anything that's going on
right now if it's properly done and
you know i'm not too educated on the
lightning network and all this other
nonsense but i will tell you what i'm
saying nonsense but
somebody's going to figure out how to
get this thing and get it to work well
and um yeah so i i think i think i think
we're just in the beginning stages and
to be clear i don't send bitcoin to
people uh around the world what i do is
i send them
a cash app i send them money to cash app
and then they then i
in some cases make a requisite that they
buy bitcoin with it because i think that
it's gonna be
uh i think it's gonna be worth more in
the future than it is today
absolutely so like you said a lot of the
stuff you've done is um
built in in some ways so talk to me
about your date today what the hell are
you doing on a day-to-day basis other
than sending money across the world well
that's a lot of it these days but um
i would say that usually what i do in
the morning is i wake up and i try to
say who can i help today and somebody
might not believe that but it's true
and i do that actually in many ways for
selfish reasons a lot of people think oh
you know you have to help people for the
sake of helping people and all this
other stuff that's correct but you also
have to help people for your own self
and so i always have that attitude who
can i help today and so frankly i look
through my twitter mentions a lot my app
mentions i mean this is crazy to think
about but sometimes i get 50.
sometimes i'll get 30 to 70 depends some
cases actually more uh mentions per
second per second
about that um
and so
you can't even imagine that
yeah so sometimes i try not to tweet for
a day or two just to be frank because
what i try to do is use that downtime
quote unquote downtime which i still get
probably and mention every
you know certainly every minute um
but
i try to use that to go through my
mentions because
usually you can see
the best people who need the most help
in the mentions i mean if somebody's
really having a hard time you know it's
you know it can be often easy to see
that person
look at my mentions you know go from
there send it to my team say hey you
know what do you think about this you
know sometimes if i need a second eye or
sometimes i'll just post the campaign
like there was this girl i don't know if
you saw this but she was seven years old
in detroit african-american girl and she
was uh mauled by a dog she was actually
eaten by a dog while she was on her body
when was that
this was
months ago but i'm just giving an
example of you know one of the cases and
so i find this out and so i'm reading
the news story and boom i just start
tweeting you know i've tried to be more
disciplined where i say okay if i'm
gonna do this you know i gotta you know
i'm just like when i see those kind of
things that pull at your heart strings
you know just like i i you know i'm
gonna make this happen and you know
another example was last summer we
helped save baby maisy i don't know if
you saw that but this young girl
18 month old was dying literally dying
and needed a terminal drug a drug to
save her from terminal um
this terminal spinal disease
and the drug company wouldn't give it to
her and so i just went
uh for lack of a better word bananas on
on twitter
i mean i probably had thousands of
people calling the team and i so
um
so yeah so
that's
there is like that background then like
you said you were asking your team to
sort of have a second look essentially
absolutely absolutely because
let's be clear i mean i'm just one guy
and what i want to do is inspire and i
think i have thousands if not
we'll go donate to the cancer patient
send links then links
but i think it's really interesting when
you said you don't necessarily do it
you do do it for yourself because
there's a part of it which makes um
which sort of helps you grow
in the reverse as an example it's kind
of like when you're not kind and when
you do something nasty in my opinion a
part of me sort of rots inside so if you
take that idea
then surely when you are kind some sort
of beauty must grow within you
that's correct in fact
i think the way that it is
physiologically is that basically you
feel good in the moment so like if you
judge somebody and you say hey you know
that person has this or something like
that
and you feel good for a moment but what
you do is you slowly
by doing that and you do it in small
steps but the small steps eventually add
up to be big steps and you become very
unhappy but what i'm saying in terms of
the small judgment is you separate
yourself from that person
and so it's in the act of separating
yourself from that person in a judgment
type of situation
you essentially detach yourself from
reality and just the way that in my
opinion and i think it's backed up but
people have to do their own research is
the way the universe is rigged is
basically if you
separate yourself from people or you
separate yourself from reality
you can basically slowly but surely
become very very unhappy and that's
actually why you see a lot of rich
people so unhappy a lot of people say to
me bill you know um you know you're one
of the happier guys like you know
you know and you don't need these jets
and all these other things which i can
afford
and
i say you know what that is a slow
motion train wreck waiting to happen and
the reason is is because all of a sudden
you know your glass of champagne is too
warm or you're you know you're not
sitting in the right seat in the
airplane or something you build up all
of these little conditionings and and it
can really you up so yeah excuse my
language but no go for it you know
um they're quite interesting actually
someone has just popped up saying you
can have a look it says i think i have a
fake account sending invested saying i
was the winner so
talk to me about that that's very
interesting do you want me that fake
accounts and how do you deal with that
because of course you know you are a
public profile and you have been accused
jobs in the past you have cleared your
name
so it must be very difficult
having to explain yourself
yeah i had some crazy people uh
i considered them stalkers because
they were
it's weird like when you go from like
zero to a hundred you get all kinds of
crazy people come out and yeah
ten percent what's that
and how quickly was that zero to 100
how what
how quickly
i mean i went from 30 000 followers and
you know july of 2019 to
you know uh two three hundred thousand
followers in a period of a week or two i
mean it was just insane so i think what
happens when you're a new guy in the
block people say oh it must be a scam oh
blah blah blah
and then i mean i hate to say it and
again i'm not trying to judge i'm just
stating a fact which is that
um
you know
people
don't uh people get envious people can
get envious and there are a couple
people unfortunately who got envious but
having said that yes
most of the people know what i say which
is i will never ask you for money in
order to get money in exchange i'll
never ask you for a bank account uh if
you do those are scammers and the only
account that you should be listening to
is my at polti account in terms of
whether you've won or not and that's a
verified account so
i know that you had one person asked
about that um but just totally honestly
uh out of three million people that
follow me uh there's always going to be
you know a handful of people who don't
know that but i would say overwhelming
majority of the people who follow me and
you can even look this up they know that
i don't do it in fact they get angry at
people like that person and i tell them
don't get angry at that person you know
it's an innocent honest question but
they get angry because they're like hey
haven't you been paying attention you
know polti never would ask you for money
in order to get
money in return so
yeah yeah actually
all of my followers because i know we
got a lot of them in here and i think
some are probably dropping off because
of the sound but please go follow leia
oh that's super kind thank you yeah i do
apologize for the audio um i'm not sure
what's going on we'll have to fix that
in the next one um but that is um lovely
you know like followers
they know you essentially so um i'm
gonna sort of um sort of ask me one last
question cause i am concerned about the
audio um but my
question for you is really
what would you say to somebody um
looking to build a business um looking
to
make
a become financially stable make
something for themselves as somebody
that's done that what would you say if
you had like three million tips for them
well i would just say the one thing is
to focus on one thing the way the
universe is rigged in my opinion is if
you want something and you want it bad
enough chances are you have a pretty
good shot at getting it but if you have
all of these desires all these
unconscious desires you want three
things six things 12 things the way the
universe is rigged and
that's the way i look at it is you won't
be successful in my opinion
i know very few people frankly i know
very few billionaires and i know very
few millionaires
who
do multiple things and make um make all
their money from multiple things most of
them know one thing in fact i became how
i became independently wealthy from my
family is i actually made my money in
heating and air conditioning uh that has
been the business that i have really um
done very well and i did own another
company uh in the building supply chain
and i did well there too
but my real expertise actually if people
want to know it is in heating and air
conditioning now you would say well bill
you know i never knew that you would do
that or who does heating and air
conditioning look
i enjoy solving problems but you know
what i focus on one thing and when it
comes to hvac heating and air
conditioning i know what i'm talking
about now if you ask me about you know
uh
you know something else like even
cryptocurrency right i don't know all
about the lightning network i mean i'm
enough to be an investor
but i'm not looking to make a fortune in
that otherwise i would be focusing on
that one thing so i would just say
the way the universe is rigged pick one
thing
oh i'm totally with you um you know
finally
i become an expert at it
and do it right basically um i am really
focused on my audience and i'm really
upset about that but bill i want to
thank you so much for coming on
um i could talk to you for ages about
kindness the universe and the way to
make magic then um but unfortunately my
audio but listen i will
have you on again because i want to go
against that time and you can call or dm
me anytime and i try to be as responsive
as possible so um
let me know and great great meeting you
and talking to you and let's hope uh for
everybody's sake that bitcoin goes to
the moon
i'm totally with you um thank you so
much and i'm gonna end the world cup
everyone who tuned in and uh we'll be in
touch
sounds good see ya bye